[Music]
communism is one of the largest and most
controversial political ideologies in
the modern world it's been adopted in
various forms by cuba china and of
course the soviet union but who
developed the tenets of communism
why is this form of government not been
adopted more widely by western nations
hi i'm rich burnett for wandrium in this
episode of perspectives five experts use
events from the last century to
illustrate the development of communism
as well as its promises and pitfalls
we start now with a definition of
communism and a picture of its reach in
the 20th century
[Music]
shortly after the second world war when
communist regimes were at their peak
it's estimated that regimes espousing
marxism ruled over a third of the world
even now
after the fall of the berlin wall the
collapse of the soviet union and its
satellite states and the transformation
of china it remains relevant especially
in places that still claim adherence to
communist ideals like north korea or
cuba
but more generally much of what is
happening in eastern europe today and in
east asia today are outcomes of the
record and consequences of communism
how and why
at the outset
it is indispensable to define communism
communism as shaped by karl marx is
defined as the abolition of private
property and a market which seeks profit
replacing these with a new system of
collective control of the means of
production and resources
associated with this were promises of
total social equality and sharing in a
new kind of stage of human societal
evolution
in fact
marx's scheme promised a liberation from
history the entire record of struggle
and exploitation and suffering to date
a later formulation of marxism was that
communism would be the stage when all of
society was organized along the lines of
one idea
from each according to his ability
to each according to his need
according to mark's labor theory of
value if people will buy the product of
a worker's labor for a hundred dollars
then that's what their labor is worth
when the capitalist only pays them fifty
dollars and then charges a hundred
so pays them only fifty dollars for
their labor but charges 100 for the
product to make a profit on the sale
they're stealing 50 from the worker and
as competition increases the
exploitation will only worsen monopolies
will appear and prices will rise which
while rate wages decrease
this will create more working poor and
even fewer jobs wealth will concentrate
in fewer and fewer people while the poor
will just get poorer and poorer and
poorer
and eventually the workers will snap and
revolt
this revolt will lead to communism in
fairly short order mark says first the
workers will take control of the
government and purge capitalism from the
system making the government socialist
it will take over the production of
goods and all industry
but the structure of that government
will eventually just dissolve there will
be no more need for a leader or for
elected officials because the people
will take control of all political
decisions and the economic life of the
country directly
and when they do they'll ensure that
there will be no more worker
exploitation no more worker alienation
and certainly no more child labor all
credit and banking will be done by the
state as will all means of communication
and transportation anyone who can work
will they might even do multiple jobs
throughout the day and the profits of
all labor will be shared by everyone in
fact there will be such an abundance
that everyone will have access to what
the labor of the workers produces
everyone will be guaranteed income free
education and free medical care from
each according to his ability to each
according to his need
that's marx's communism
on july 16 1918 several members of the
russian royal family including a father
his wife their five children and
servants were murdered by bolshevik
revolutionaries and dumped into unmarked
graves
the royal family patriarch tsar nicholas
ii had actually been deposed months
before his murder ending 300 years of
romanov family rule
and now revolution was underway across
all segments of society the military
radical leftists and elites many of them
fleeing
what would follow is the creation of a
vast new state known as the soviet union
this was a major experiment that would
test the communist theories of karl marx
as well as endless subsets of this
experiment with such names as the great
industrialization debate nep and their
nadir the star trials of the 1930s in
which brute force prevailed over
collective aims or ideals
so the origins of the soviet union go
back to a time when world war one had
exhausted the russian people and led to
the deaths of millions of russian
peasants conscripted into the tsarist
army
karl marx left no detailed description
of what a real functioning communist
economy would look like
but he assumed that communism would
first triumph in a modern developed
capitalist economy with sophisticated
managers and literate skilled workers
he certainly didn't envision communism
starting in such a poor backward
agricultural and largely illiterate
society as early 20th century russia
consequently vladimir lenin and his
fellow russian bolshevik communists had
to more or less make up the new economic
system on their own when they seized
power
the bolsheviks who constituted the
majority faction of the russian social
democratic party that had seized power
decided on a system of direct control
over the economy
as you probably know mark's theory
wasn't exactly vindicated in the long
run as homer simpson once said
in theory communism works in theory
in reality not so much
what went wrong
well
first
it's well known today that his labor
theory of value is wrong although to be
fair it was the standard theory at the
time smith accepted it as well
much more than the cost of labor
determines the value of a product a
product's utility supply and demand and
a host of other factors are also
relevant otherwise how does the price of
oil fluctuate so consistently
what's more marx failed to take into
account that capitalists are owed some
compensation for their efforts not only
do they do the leg work to create the
business in the first place but they
take financial risks that workers do not
after all there's no guarantee the
product will sell so contrary to mark's
suggestion
charging more than it costs to make
something does not always amount to
theft the kind of theft that he thought
motivated and justified a worker
revolution
more importantly many of mark's
predictions were just
flat out wrong
for example he said communism would
first arise in the most developed
nations
it did not the most famous communist
revolution happened in russia in 1917 uh
when russia's economy was extremely
primitive and most developed nations
never saw a communist revolt at all
history is full of surprises
in 1988 no one knew that the long cold
war was about to come to a sudden end
american universities were full of
sovietologists while the cia defense
department state department and national
security council all kept a close watch
on events in eastern europe russia and
its satellite republics
they could see that the soviet union was
no match economically for the west
that no one believed in communism
anymore
and the decay drunkenness and
disillusionment were widespread
they could see that a ruinous and failed
intervention in afghanistan had bled
soviet armies and prompted widespread
desertion
they were however slow to recognize that
mikhail gorbachev soviet premier since
1986 was not willing to use force to
preserve the soviet empire
president reagan while speaking at
berlin's brandenburg gate in 1987 had
declared mr gorbachev tear down this
wall
just two years later the wall did come
down amid scenes of rejoicing and
reconciliation
east and west berliners mingled freely
for the first time since 1961
and before long germans from both sides
were planning reunification
when the soviet flag was lowered for the
last time from the top of the kremlin
and the tri-color flag of the russian
federation was raised in its place no
jubilant crowd stood shouting hurrah
however
no statues were ripped from their bases
no figure was burned in effigy
no group of revolutionaries embraced the
seemingly impossible as having been
accomplished
instead
newspaper reports described a sense of
uncertainty
as a small group of onlookers watched
this historic moment
unfold some
felt more than a little regret
one young woman told a reporter for the
new york times
i'm sorry for the soviet union
i'm sad
i'm sorry a great country is falling
apart before my eyes
as we now know the transition from
communism in the culture of a one-party
state to capitalism and democracy would
be exponentially more difficult than
exchanging one flag for another
communist apparatchiks didn't suddenly
become liberal democrats
they had a vested interest in
maintaining their prerogatives of power
and influence
many had exploited the system and even
pilfered from the state for years
decades of economic atrophy corruption
bribery secrecy and privileged access
also lingered
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here